- All right, let's wrap up the hour.
Something super sweet
I found scrolling social.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheers)
Growing up,
Michael was all about football,
baseball, and wrestling.
And when he had little girls,
he hoped they'd have
his competitive spirit.
And boy do they.
It just happens to be
in a different sport.
They're cheerleaders.
And now he's happily
become a tried and true,
"Cheer Dad".
Even practicing the routines
with his girls like this.
- Five, six, seven, eight.
One, two, three, four, five, seven.
One, go, three,
five, seven, dip,
four, five, seven, and,
one, two, three, five.
(audience cheers)
- Oh my gawd,
I love your family.
Okay, go Michael!
We have him on the line right now
along with his daughters,
Josie, who you saw in that video,
and her older sister, Anabelle.
What's up everybody?
How y'all doing?
(audience cheers)
- [Michael] Hey.
- [Josie and Anabelle] Hey.
- Oh my gosh.
So Michael, I'm gonna start with you.
What's it like to be a cheer dad?
- Oh, it's awesome.
So about three years ago,
Anabelle and Josie got involved
in All Star Cheerleading.
And, ever since then I've
grown to love the sport.
I taught myself how to teach them
how to do cheers
and every day we'll go outside,
we'll stunt in the front yard,
I'll help 'em with their tumbling.
And it's really been a bonding experience
between all three of us.
And, we've just grown
to love the cheer sport.
- Oh, it's incredible.
That's so cool.
So Annabelle and Josie,
how's your dad as a cheerleader?
How do you think?
- He's getting better
every time I teach him.
(audience laughs)
Because,
when we stunt in the yard
and work on our flexibility,
and he's a great dad.
- Aww,
I love that.
What about you, Josie?
- He's good.
He always comes to all my competitions.
He's so proud.
I always hear him say,
"Go Josie!"
And all of my friends say,
"Is that your dad saying, 'Go Josie,'
when everybody's quiet?"
I'm like,
"Yeah, that's him."
(audience cheers)
(Kelly claps)
(Kelly laughs)
- I love it.
That's amazing.
So Anabelle and Josie,
I heard that you have a new cheer
that you wanna share, right?
- Yes.
- All right!
Let's see it!
- One.
- One, two, three,
Kelly!
Let's spell it!
K-
E-
L-L-
Y!
That's right!
Dance to it!
Go Kelly!
Period!
(audience cheers)
(Kelly laughs)
- My God!
I love you guys!
Oh my gosh!
I'm gonna watch that footage
anytime I'm ever feeling down.
That made me feel so good.
Thank you ladies.
Thank you Michael, Anabelle, Josie,
I'm liking your post right now.
I'm loving your family
(bell dings)
even more.
And that's not all you guys,
our season long partner, Pilot Pen,
makers of Friction,
the go to erasable pen of
the Kelly Clarkson Show,
want to celebrate those
creating fearlessly,
and cheering fearlessly,
just like you.
So they're gonna give
you a thousand dollars.
How's that sound?
(everyone cheers)
And thank you so much, Michael
for being such a great daddy.
That's an incredible,
cool thing you're doing with your girls.
Thank you to all our guests this hour.
Juliette Lewis, Ben and Erin Napier,
and Montana Tucker.
Y'all have a great day
and if it's not, try and change it.